Estamos ya en el problema 58 y dice, la gráfica de la ecuación
"y" igual a "x" cuadrada -3x -4 se muestra aquí abajo ¿Para que valores de "x" es "y" igual a 0?
Muy bien, entonces nos muestran estas cuatro opciones y nos preguntan cuándo "y" es igual a 0.
Entonces lo que hay que recordar es que "y" igual a 0, si nos consideramos no todos los puntos en el plano, sino
aquellos donde su segunda coordenada es 0, entonces en realidad estamos hablando
del eje "x".
Este eje "x" es del que estamos hablando en el problema,
entonces si "y" es igual a 0 en principio, uno podría resolver esta ecuación ¿Verdad? Por que lo que uno tiene es que,
que "x" cuadrada -3x -4 es igual a "y" pero en este caso es 0.
Entonces uno podría intentar resolver la ecuación, sin embargo aquí ya nos están dando
una gráfica, entonces no es necesario hacerlo ya que podemos localizarlos muy bien aquí, por ejemplo
aquí está la primera
intersección de la gráfica con el eje "x" ¿Verdad? Que es cuando "y" es igual a 0 y aquí está el otro, entonces
"x" uno de ellos es -1 y él y la otra coordenada es igual a
4 que justamente es la opción "c" ¿Muy bien? Vámonos con el siguiente problema.
Dice ¿Cuáles de las siguientes gráficas
representa mejor a la de "y" igual a -"x" cuadrada más 3? Entonces para hacer esto lo que quiero hacer es
recordar cómo se ven las siguientes gráficas.
Digamos tengo aquí
mis ejes coordenados aquí está la coordenada "y",
aquí la vertical es la coordenada "y" la coordenada "x" es la horizontal
como siempre y quiero que recordemos quién es la gráfica,
de "y" igual a "x" cuadrada, "y" igual a "x" al cuadrado.
Entonces está por supuesto es una parábola, que tiene el vértice en el origen en el
0,0 abre hacia arriba es la parábola más,
más sencilla que tenemos ¿Verdad? Y en realidad abre de esta forma por que es bastante
simétrica. Lo mismo vale si andamos
de las "x" positivas que desde las "x"
negativas ¿Verdad? Por ejemplo 1 al cuadrado es igual a - 1 al cuadrado, o si tiene uno
100 al cuadrado es lo mismo que -100 al cuadrado. Entonces esto es muy
simétrico, además siempre es positivo ¿Verdad? Cualquier número elevado al cuadrado
es positivo, entonces yo espero que ya estés bien
familiarizado con quién es la gráfica de esta función. Ahora bien ¿Qué pasa si nosotros nos tomamos
"y" igual a -"x" cuadrada?
Esencialmente es la misma gráfica sólo que ahora todos los valores van a ser
negativos, entonces cumple la misma propiedad de ser muy simétrica,
sigue siendo esta parábola, solo que ahora abre hacia
abajo ¿Verdad? Son puros números negativos de hecho lo podríamos pensar como, como si
reflejaramos en una espejo la gráfica de "x" cuadrada ¿Verdad? Si esta parábola se ve al espejo,
así es como ella se vería a sí misma.
¿Muy bien? Entonces ya para ir redondeando quién sería entonces la gráfica de "x" cuadrada más 3
¿Muy bien? Entonces todos los valores me están diciendo que a todos los valores de "x" cuadrada
ahora le estamos sumando 3, entonces realmente
esto es equivalente a desplazar nuestra parábola hacia arriba 3 unidades ¿Muy bien?
Simplemente está desplazando la parábola 3 unidades.
Ahora ¿qué pasa si yo tengo "y" igual,
"y" igual a - "x" cuadrada más 3, pues también la gráfica rosa que es la que
corresponde a -"x" cuadrada la estamos trasladando 3 unidades hacia arriba.
Entonces es exactamente la misma
sólo que desplazada 3 unidades hacia arriba ¿Muy bien? Entonces nos fijamos en la parábola
digamos naranja, y nos fijamos que la opción es la B ¿Verdad? Tiene su
vértice en él , en el número igual a 3 en la coordenada
0,3 ¿Verdad? También es lo que le llaman la intersección con el eje "y" o la
ordenada al origen en fin y además abre hacia abajo, entonces es la única que cumple esas 2 propiedades, así que
elegimos la gráfica B.
Vamos con el problema 60.
¿Cuál de las funciones cuadráticas al graficarla tiene intersecciones con el eje "x" en 4 y - 3?
Entonces fíjense que si tomamos una ecuación
cuadrática, si nos tomamos una ecuación cuadrática, en realidad si
interceptamos en "x" igual a 4 y en "x" igual a -3, tenemos algo de la siguiente forma. Un número que al
ser 4 se debe anular entonces es "x" - 4 ¿Verdad? Si yo aquí pongo un
4 - 4 se anula, y esto debe multiplicar a otro factor ¿Ok? Estamos encontrando nuestra función cuadrática
debe
multiplicar a un factor que evaluado en -3 se anule, entonces si le sumáramos 3
en, aquí si "x" es -3, -3 más 3 se anula entonces más o menos
en principio más o menos podría ser esta gráfica pero, si
nos fijamos aquí no hay ninguna respuesta que se le parezca. Ahora bien si esto es igual a 0,
digamos si esto lo igualamos a 0 y nosotros
multiplicamos lo de la izquierda, de hecho de ambos lados ¿Verdad? Si multiplicamos de ambos lados
por cualquier constante digamos, no sé
esté, "y" igual a una constante que multiplica a "x" - 4 por "x" más 3,
si multiplicamos por una constante distinta de 0, pues la igualdad se sigue, se sigue conservando ¿Verdad?
Entonces realmente esta constante me permite
variar un poquito del resultado en el sentido de que, por ejemplo esta opción de B
aquí esto es 2 veces
"x" - 4 ¿Verdad?.
Sigue teniendo las mismas raíces, por esto que dijimos no importa si yo tengo aquí una constante,
por que después puedo dividir entre esa
constante y regreso a la ecuación original ¿Verdad? Entonces no importa si multiplicamos por
una constante en este caso, esta constante
valdría 2. Las raíces siguen siendo las mismas, por lo tanto la respuesta aquí,
la mejor respuesta, de hecho la única respuesta es B.
¿Ok? Entonces vamos con el siguiente ejercicio 61.
¿Cuántas veces
intersecta la gráfica de "y" igual a 2x cuadrada -2x más 3 al eje "x"?
Entonces realmente sabemos que una parábola, pues podría interceptar al eje "x" una,
2 o varias veces ¿Verdad? Por ejemplo
este puede ser algo así, como una parábola de esta forma, donde cruza dos veces puede ser una
parábola de esta forma, donde no cruza ninguna, o puede ser una parábola de esta forma ¿Verdad?.
Algo así donde cruza solo una vez, entonces ¿Cómo determinamos esto? Bueno pues vamos
a encontrar las raíces utilizando la fórmula
cuadrática o la solución ¿Verdad? Nosotros sabemos que es -"b" más -la raíz
de "b" cuadrada -4 ac y todo eso entre 2, entonces entre 2 veces "a".
Entonces eso ya lo vimos en la fórmula cuadrática, sólo vamos a irlo aterrizando con estos números
que tenemos aquí, entonces -"b" es
menos -2, que es 2 más - la raíz de "b" cuadrada que es -2 al cuadrado y eso es 4
- 4 que multiplica a "a"
que en este caso es 2, y luego multiplicamos a "c" que en este caso es 3 sobre
2 veces "a" que es 2. Entonces en vez de 2 le pongo de una vez 4, entonces
fíjense muy bien esto, bueno será igual a 2 más - la raíz de
4 - 3 por 4 son 12, por 2 son 24
todo esto sobre 4 y 4 -24 es -20 esto de aquí es
- 20, entonces necesitamos sacar la raíz cuadrada
de un número negativo y eso es imposible en el conjunto de los números reales.
Así que como realmente no podemos obtener una solución real, no hay o más bien hay ninguna solución
a esa ecuación, que es equivalente a interceptar la gráfica de esta ecuación
cuadrática, cuando "y" es igual a 0 ¿Verdad? En la intersección con el eje "x".
Vámonos con el último problema.
Dice un objeto que es lanzado hacia abajo con velocidad inicial de "v" pies por segundo
recorre una distancia
"s" igual a vt más 16t cuadrada donde "t" es el tiempo en segundos.
Si Benito se encuentra en un balcón a
84 pies por encima del suelo y arroja una moneda con una velocidad inicial de 10 pies por segundo
¿En cuántos segundos alcanzará el
suelo? ¿Muy bien? Entonces vamos a hacer un pequeño dibujo de eso.
Digamos que aquí se encuentre Benito, no sé por qué esté en un balcón pero, ahí anda
jugando con sus monedas y deja caer una moneda
por 84 pies,
si está exacto, está 84 pies de altura ¿Muy bien? Entonces nuestra distancia que va a recorrer es 84.
La pregunta es ¿En cuánto tiempo? Realmente tenemos que encontrar la "t",
ahora bien la "v" que es la velocidad con la que, si la velocidad inicial
aquí nos está diciendo que es de 10 pies por segundo, entonces esto será 10 veces "t" más
16t cuadrada y tengo que hallar "t" por que quiero encontrar el número de segundos
que tardará la moneda en caer al suelo.
Entonces lo que se me ocurre es
pasar el 84 del lado derecho, al restar de ambos lados 84 entonces tendremos
déjenme, déjenme cambiar el orden, tendremos 16t cuadrada más 10t, eso es esto de aquí de la derecha.
Esto es 84
entonces si yo resto 84 de ambos lados tenemos 16t cuadrada más 10t
- 84 igual a 0. Entonces esto ya es una ecuación
cuadrática podremos por ejemplo dividir entre 2
de ambos lados y nos queda 8t cuadrada más  5t
-42 debe ser igual a 0 también.
¿Muy bien? Entonces ya con esto podemos utilizar nuevamente la fórmula cuadrática y ver para
qué valores debe tener "t".
Entonces sabemos que "t"
tiene 2 valores ¿Verdad? Esto será - "b" que es -5
más - la raíz de "b" cuadrada, 5 al cuadrado es 25,
-4 por 8 por -42, entonces los menos, lo voy a poner así -4
por 8 por -42
esto sobre 2 veces 8 es 16.
¿Muy bien? Entonces seguimos desarrollando y esto es -5 más - la raíz de
25, y aquí queda claro que el menos por el menos da más ¿Ok? Entonces va a ser más
4 por 8, 32 por 42 entonces 32 por 42 ¿Cuánto es? 2 por 2 son 4, 2 por 3 son
6, 4 por 2 son 8, 4 por 3 son 12
4, 6 y 8, 14 y llevamos 1,1 y 2 son 3, 1344
1344 y si le sumamos 25 de una vez son 1369
¿ Verdad? 1300...
Perdón esto es 1369 que ya lo limpiamos,
Va a ser
1369 y todo esto sobre 16, entonces ahora la pregunta ya esencial es ¿Cuánto es la raíz cuadrada de 1369?
Déjenme sacar la calculadora.
Entonces 1369 ,
1369 y la raíz cuadrada son 37.
Entonces esto es -5  más -37
sobre 16. Ahora bien nosotros necesitamos que el tiempo sea positivo por que pues no tiene sentido
pensar que en un tiempo
negativo, la moneda va a estar en el suelo ¿Verdad?
No es como que estuviera en el suelo y saltó a la mano de Benito ¿Están de
acuerdo? Así que realmente sólo me debo quedar con el que tiene signo más
y si me quedo solo con el que tiene el signo más
esto será
37 - 5 son 32 entre 16 que son 2, así que la respuesta correcta son
2 segundos. Lo que tarda la moneda en caer al suelo ¿Muy bien?
Entonces de todas formas ahora nos veremos en el próximo vídeo.